août 1979 le cyclone david effleure la
guadeloupe
derrière lui laisse des milliers de
bananier plié en deux des arbres et des
poteaux arraché importe où neuf détruit
les enfants de l'école du carmel avatar
raconte dans la file devant un puits et
de la pluie qui se font depuis la mi
août avec la vague d'arrêts ya cette
année en question de mariage
honda prépare le feu m le joaillier
combal et la joie qui se fait dans le
char ce qui peut être calculé
petit plus il est beaucoup de gens
sincèrement maison et on ne parle aussi
de quel que sorte qu'ils pourront se
vanter d'un suspect
moi j'ai vu que de nous dire ça qu'ils
se sentent et surtout le port de basket
est engagée parce que tout le monde par
ses lames et rasé et j'ai vu les gens
ici à quelques visas
à cause de david la rentrée a été
retardée l'eau les seuils les branches
avaient envahi d'école mais bientôt ce
sera noël et pour les petits
guadeloupéens les vacances se passeront
à la plage on jouera également dans les
jardins où la nature a repris ses droits
noël ici ce sont les fleurs les hibiscus
les anthuriums les six mois vers six
mois rouge les halles amanda
les chansons tout blanc ce n'est pas la
neige bien sûr mais les plages de cannes
qui se dressent vers le ciel
je vais vous parler comment nous
préparons le goût des choses aux
antilles on se lève de très bonnes à
quoi la veille
on laisse là on laisse la cour de flore
le port sans manger puis le jour suivant
tokyo entière au chaud on prend un sens
l'année à gouye et on enlève la peau
c'est les effets des boudins cochon pois
d'angole c'est le menu traditionnel avec
ce sens nous mêlons j'en avais vu fait
et se paie nous donne la force et
beaucoup des commandes afin aussi de
froid on met dans la peau de rage h et à
sécher ensuite quand l essec faits sont
là mais à tromper d'hommes du roi
ensuite en voiture
ta peau on prépare du sioe on met la
cimo d'or vers la terre
non c'est pour les grandes personnes
les petits guadeloupéens de basterds ont
déjà reçu un cadeau leurs camarades de
royan ne les ont pas oubliés michaud
weyessa leur façon à eux de les
remercier
le billet vert une lumière il se mit à
chanter je vois deux rames livrables et
il te quitte à chanter je leur dis moi
dis moi c'est pas du bien qui sera
témoin le circuit
l'inimitié willem higelin michaud